Okay so
a lot of people think that I'm hard on
women
and I think that's a fair Affair
criticism I do criticize the women a lot
but I want to let you guys in on a
little secret of people that irritate me
more
than delusional women on the show
because anyone that knows me behind the
scenes
will know
there is a type of person that annoys me
more than delusional women okay
simp men
now why do men annoy me
because the simps make the women
delusional
I couldn't figure out why on my shows I
would continually have to argue things
with men of things that me and the men
both know are true for example
men don't like women with high body
counts and I kept thinking why am I
having to argue with men that they like
women with higher body counts when I
know that they don't when they pick a
woman they don't have a high body count
on top of that same with the fat thing
I say hey men don't like fat chicks then
I'm arguing with these guys because
they'll be like hey I like a woman with
a little something something and I'm
like okay but you know you don't like a
girl with a big waist you like slim
waist big butt like let's just call
spade a spade why am I arguing like this
like it's so frustrating when you you're
arguing something with someone
who knows it's true or hey you don't
like I know
that men like younger women
and women over 30 it's not their first
pick
and they'll argue hey I date some women
over 30. you know I like my women
intellectually whatever the men don't
give a [__] about how smart you are I
mean maybe a little bit but you know it
starts with looks and I would get so
frustrated okay these guys will
frustrate me more than the women more
because I think that women on some level
believe this [__] I think women are
delusional but the men
act delusional but they know the truth
because of their men and they listen to
how men talk and what I realize is the
Sims don't want ladies ladies the simps
are lying to us because they want to
sleep with us and they don't want to
eliminate their options so they'll come
on a show and say I like women with high
body counts knowing well they would
never wipe them but they'll say this
because
they want to sleep with us all right
then then
they'll do the same thing with the
chubby chicks they don't want to ruin
their options with the chubby chicks so
they'll Pander and say
raise your standards because the simps
don't want the game to change
because if women said you know what
we're going to be better women we're
gonna get in relationships and we're
gonna actually become what men want
we're gonna stop messing around in this
crazy dating world and get married
um and this is especially common with
simps that get laid let's stop acting
like all simps
all panderers are these men that never
get laid no a lot of them do get laid
and they don't want the game to change
and so what they'll do is they'll say I
date modern women I date old women I
date fat women no we know damn well that
if you look at their last girlfriend not
[__] buddy sorry Auntie told me to stop
swearing this much screw buddy all right
you know damn well
I'm sorry I'm sorry you know
that they would not be fat you know they
would not be super old or older than
them by a lot
you know their first choice is younger
hotter tighter let's just
but they lie because if the game changes
and if they're honest about their
preferences they don't get as many women
and so what they'll do is they'll lie at
the women's expense and tell us what we
want to hear tell us that we can expect
the world tell us that these 50 50
partnership type [__] works when we
see in real time how 50 50 Partnerships
work seriously what examples of 50 50
Partnerships where the woman runs the
relationship in Media or be really
trying to emulate let's look at JLo
do we want to be in a relationship like
JLo do we want to be in a relationship
like Kim Kardashian was in with Kanye do
we want to be in a relationship like all
of these celebrity women that decided to
go and run their relationships now this
isn't to say that I'm perfect or
whatever but this is to say that these
simps are going to lie to you
and these symptoms will lie to us
and we're the ones going out there
making these decisions that have
consequences where the simps have more
time to get married settle down where
for women if you make too many bad
decisions when when we're young
it actually might be over for you so
I appreciate the shows that actually
tell the truth about women because you
know what that's at least honest but
simps will lie to you
Sims will discredit you and simps will
attack a girl with a podcast personally
instead of attack what I say
um
I'm tired of these steps I'm tired of
the panderers and I'm tired of these men
that tell women what we want to hear
because
they want to get laid
thank you welcome to my TED talk like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel ring that notification Bell
I'll talk to you next time